ma che animale sei ti farò un bellissimo
ritratto
ecco qua pennelli tela la cooper gli
acquerelli rimane fermo così gli ok
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma ti piace proprio cantare ma cos'è
questo l'ho trovato aspetta piace tanto
cantare quindi volevo aspettare che
finisse di cantare questo e l'animaletto
che si è mangiato tutto il mio cibo
sì è proprio lui è che cosa è in realtà
non lo so
c'era questo biglietto in cui si è
scritto che è un ghismo o un grembo
l'ing qualcosa del genere ma non è
troppo carino si mangia il mio 5 va ad
essere carino benissimo è vero è tanto
carino però si mangia tutto il mio cibo
e voi non possiamo mica te lerno così
dobbiamo vedere dobbiamo chiedere a
merlino se è d'accordo è d'accordo
marino berlino sembra d'accordo
merlino sei d'accordo a tenervi smo
dotato di rho a me sembra che abbia
detto di sì ora lasciami un momento in
pace che devo fare il suo ritratto
grazie berlino berlino ha accettato di
avere un nuovo fratellino e cioè ghismo
evitare la luce troppo forte non dargli
da mangiare dopo mezzanotte e non
bagnarlo mai ti ti va bene va bene
oramai è ancora un momento chi smo quasi
finito il tuo ritratto però promettimi
di non offenderti ok non sei proprio
uguale ok ho finito sei pronto 32
ti piace perché non dice niente
forse vuoi vederlo un po più da vicino
non ti piace o no lo bagnato subito a
prendere qualcosa stesso ca
[Musica]
che succede
ismo un altro anno è stata tutta colpa
mia io bagnati con l'acqua cielo bagnate
sono diventati due questo è proprio un
bel guaio
devo subito uno stop prima che a
rivisitare merlino mi raccomando tu non
hai visto niente ok non se ne accorgerà
mai vero no no non ha scosso qua mi
raccomando berlino non dire niente
avvitare ok è il nostro segreto
ora segreto niente intendevo dire che
berlina segrete cioè che ha mangiato o
sceneggiato ha mangiato hai mangiato
maggiore molto padrone bravo velino che
cosa io vi dico non si deve dire niente
torna pure in cucina
va bene sono i viola allora sì che stai
tenere i segreti chi tra di nasconderlo
ma che noi non abbiamo nessun segreto
berlino stavo questo lo giocando niente
niente non sta facendo niente
anche sul bello non c'è niente qua
dietro fammi vedere non c'è niente da
nascondere armi perché strano ma niente
le lettere vit
eppure l'ho detto che non c'è niente non
sono così sicuro di aver visto un altro
come può essercene un altro lo so forse
ho avuto questa stranissima illusione
ottica che cosa nasconda dietro parte
non li non sta cercando di dirti
qualcosa
merlino vuoi uscire riuscire a berlino
sta cercando di dirmi dietro casa perché
consente ai gay non ci credo ti stai
nascondendo qualcosa che cos'è farvi
vedere non si stanno scambiando qualche
volta guarda buono e gentili stavolta è
scappato dove saranno andato a
nascondersi o quell'altro ismo berlino
berlino dove padroncino wapa
vediamo che cosa ci fai nascosta dietro
turismo come lo quando diventa le due
società pensa di saperlo
dai vieni ti spiego praticamente stanno
dipingendo ritratto di chi smo si pu
bellissimo l'artista non ha capito
perché ci sono turismo mi è caduta
l'acqua
ti ricordi che una delle regole era di
non bagnarsi esatto è moltiplicata o no
adesso come facciamo lo dobbiamo
regalare a qualcuno o la tempo io come
tu genere uno li chiamerò ghismo e di
sma non lo so non mi sembra una buona
idea perché il nostro carini sì sì è
vero sono super carini ma sono due
non ti preoccupare non farò più nessuno
di questi errori diamo berlino cosa ne
pensa berlino cosa ne pensi marina si
accorge di nulla fino facciamo che
decide berlino
allora merlino posso tenerli cosa ne
pensi io ho detto che va bene purché non
lasciamo dormire 20 ora dobbiamo fare
mentre il tè delle cinque io i miei
grandi chiuso come si chiamano quindi la
se ci tranquillizza 8 berlino est e
berlino gli amici
[Musica]
il bambino si mangiano di trattarli come
se fossero dei tuoi fratellini
ok ho fatto questo è per voi e questo
per me salute
[Musica]
sono contenta che ti piaccia tanto
questo the ghismo leghismo eto'o
bismarck sì c'è anche qualcosa da
mangiare ci sono questi biscotti visto
che vi piace tanto mangiare vi sembra
proprio come vitale ecco gli scritti
piano piano se stessi ma li avete
mangiati tutti rizzo berlino questi
mangiano più di te e anche più di vitale
forse non è strano berlino si è offeso
perché non ho dato a lui biscotti
berlino sei geloso ma allora sono così
carini corta sembrano così buoni dolci
anche se hanno mangiato tutto
beh allora come faceva e abbiamo con 36
di biscotti o che bella i biscotti o
figli di tutti
purtroppo si è mosso più niente male
vero molta fame avevano molta fame si
sono andato tutto di spina cielo erano i
suoi biscotti ma meno avevano molta fame
sa impacciato tantissimo quasi più di
berlino che cosa tremo di trovare subito
la famiglia che li adotti allora noi non
possiamo mica tenerli 2 manzoni cui in
più così certo che possiamo tenerli
molti sono miei
nichilismo e mi crei umili normali
daremo proprio a nessuno lo so proprio
brutto presentimento è arrivata all'ora
di andare a dormire poi dormirete qua mi
raccomando fate da bravi
ecco la vostra copertina buonanotte
ghismo vole note di sma a domani
marino
[Musica]
[Applauso]